last week president trump signed four
very aggressive executive orders to
slash drug prices
and as expected big pharma oh they're
fighting back
here's what the ceo of pfizer said on an
earnings call today
i'm disappointed by this executive
orders they pose
enormous destruction at a time where the
industry
needs to be completely focused on
developing a potential covet 19
vaccine or treatment we have plans to
invest in both
r d and manufacturing in the united
states
it finalized these new executive orders
would force us to rethink those
plans ah well
pfizer of course everyone knows is an
amazing american company
but his grousing about profits
is absurd now last week hhs and the
pentagon announced that
it would pay pfizer and its german
biotech partner
1.95 billion dollars to produce
a hundred million doses of a covet 19
vaccine
with the option of buying an additional
500 million doses so you do the math
there
so there's no reason u.s citizens should
be paying more than
other oecd countries for
other drugs that you know pfizer makes
that's the whole point of this executive
order
the upcharge is absurd now here to
respond to senator josh hawley of
missouri senator
you just heard the ceo of pfizer
essentially
threatening to move manufacturing
overseas because of these executive
orders
what does this tell you
well it tells you that they are very
interested in their profits and the
the gravy train that they've had going
for years listen i have no sympathy for
big pharma
whatsoever they routinely charge
americans
two and three and four times more for
the same drugs
that they charge patients in say europe
france
and i know this is true because we've
done studies on it my home state of
missouri they're charging
people in missouri three and four and
five times more than they're charging
folks
in france or germany or canada and i'm
glad that the president's standing up to
him
well and i think again the money that is
given by the drug companies
uh to the both political parties it's
astronomical they're among the biggest
donors
to politics in the united states and
that's fine that's what they do
but let's let's not all think this is
all just charitable endeavors i mean
it's a business it's a company
but they've gotten a free ride and i
want to ask you senator about
the president's decision the
administration's decision
to give kodak a boost in order to keep
some medical manufacturing in the united
states there are a lot of conservatives
out there
free marketeers who would say we're
playing
favorites and to that you say
well i'd say listen it is important that
we manufacture as many pharmaceutical
products as we can
in this country the fact that we
manufacture so few
drugs any longer particularly drugs like
insulin we manufacture
zero percent in this country uh major
pharmaceutical
products we've found because of the cova
19 crisis that we are
deeply dependent on foreign supply
chains so i think it is incumbent
to look at all the options for bringing
those supply chains back
for getting medical production back in
this country and was to go back to big
pharma
you know again i don't have any sympathy
for these guys this big pharma big
government alliance has been great for
big pharma they've made a killing
these last few years really for decades
and it's time they started putting
patients first
and senator a couple of weeks back
speaking of biden
he said that we should re-examine
trump's tariffs on china of course
that's the whole reason china came to
the bargaining table on these trade
deals
but today biden came out and pretended
that he was going to be the one after
four decades plus in washington
to put america first watch
using federal dollars that have already
been appropriated to focus them on
building things that make us and
increase our independence
so we don't have to rely on anyone else
for whether it's cyber security and
cyber information
we have the capacity to do at home do
them at home
okay senator is it my mistake
or not am i remember remembering this
incorrectly
wasn't he vice president in an
administration for eight years
i must have missed all that work on
these issues of bringing manufacturing
back to the united states
the problem with joe biden is that he is
a classic china appeaser
and he has been his whole political
career he certainly was
as vice president i mean heck even
earlier this year
he was questioning whether china was
really a geo-strategic threat now
that 10 turned out to be a little bit of
a problem for him
as we've seen with covet 19 which is why
he doesn't want to talk about those past
statements now but this is a guy who has
never stood up to china in fact
he has been all too eager to roll out
the red carpet for china give them
whatever they want
sell out our jobs sell out our workers
that's the problem we're still cleaning
up from his mess
of years ago and why would we go back to
those failed policies well we don't need
more appeasement
we need to get tough on china this
president started to do it we need even
more of that
uh senator uh i wouldn't let you get
away without
what you said this past weekend where
you said
quite candidly that you wouldn't support
a supreme court nominee
unless he or she had publicly stated
before the nomination that
roe versus wade was wrongly decided now
is that a litmus test that even some
republicans will back away from
what's your response you know you can
call it whatever you want laura i call
it asking some basic questions about
judicial philosophy and i also call it
the end of the
trust us approach i mean for years
conservatives especially religious
conservatives let's be honest
have been told by the d.c establishment
just trust us you know i mean we'll pick
good judges just trust us don't
ask too many questions certainly don't
ask about roe
just trust us well i'm through with that
i want to know because roe is absolutely
central roe
is an unbridled act of judicial
imperialism
and if a nominee thinks that roe was
rightly decided
then he or she is a judicial imperialist
and i'm not going to vote for him
i still got to get collins and murkowski
to sign on to any potential supreme
court pick but
i would agree with you that you look at
robert's record and
even gorsuch on some issues and you
wonder what the heck
happened there trust but verify i guess
that's what you have to do senator
great to see you as always on these
important issues thanks so much